[Música]
más de 260 militares ucranianos salieron
de la planta de 'las hostal donde
permanecía el último bastión de mariupol
imágenes muestran que los soldados
estarían bajo el poder ruso en la región
de donges mientras moscú quiere
juzgarlos quien espera un canje por
prisioneros de guerra
la unión europea responderá con todas
las medidas que tenga a su disposición
así reaccionó bruselas ante el anuncio
del gobierno de reino unido en presentar
un proyecto de ley que modificaría
unilateralmente el protocolo de irlanda
del norte una parte fundamental del
pacto luego del próximo
la supremacía blanca es un veneno en
eeuu así lo afirmó el presidente joe
biden desde búfalo nueva york antes de
reunirse con los familiares de las 10
personas que fueron asesinadas el sábado
por un supremacista la mayoría de las
víctimas eran afroamericanos
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
los saluda maría clara calle y es un
placer acompañarlos y comenzamos con la
actualidad de la guerra en ucrania por
lo menos 264 combatientes ucranianos
salieron de la planta de asof tal donde
está el último bastión de la resistencia
en mariupol ellos fueron trasladados
hacia don yesca a una zona controlada
por separatistas pro rusos
moscú habla de rendición pero aquí efe
espera que haya un canje por prisioneros
de guerra por su parte las autoridades
ucranianas aseguran que todavía hay
personas dentro de la acería pero no
precisaron cuántas si esta fábrica cae
mariupol se convertiría en la ciudad más
grande que ha tomado músculo desde el
inicio de lo que ellos califican como
una operación especial el reporte lo
tiene ariana villacorta
en siete buses partieron los
combatientes ucranianos que resistieron
durante semanas al asedio ruso dentro
del complejo de asustar en mariupol su
destino zonas bajo el control de los
rusos en lo que rusia calificó de
rendición masiva
ayer comenzó la rendición de los
militantes de la unidad nacionalista y
los soldados ucranianos bloqueados en la
planta 2 tal de mariupol en las últimas
24 horas 265 militantes depusieron las
armas y se rindieron incluidos 51
heridos graves
el presidente de la cámara baja del
parlamento ruso se refirió a ellos como
criminales de guerra mientras que la
vice primera ministra de ucrania aseguró
que la operación fue una evacuación
coordinada con el enemigo y que aspiraba
a un intercambio de prisioneros
como muchos otros por nuestra parte
podemos decir que el proceso de
negociación está en marcha y que la
propia operación de rescate está en
marcha
arrastro para el gobierno la resistencia
en el puerto hasta hoy fue fundamental
en el curso de la guerra
la defensa sostenida por nuestros
defensores de mariupol no permitió que
el enemigo redistribuyeran sus fuerzas
alrededor de 20.000 efectivos
somos cuatro protón y conos el enemigo
no pudo redistribuirse a otras regiones
y no fue capaz de capturar rápidamente a
la policía - ruth con los ojos puestos
en su posición aunque simbólica la
resistencia de asos tal no supuso mucha
diferencia para los bandos porque rusia
había trasladado la mayor parte de sus
fuerzas desde mariupol hace semanas
en este punto para los ucranianos las
fuerzas en mariupol habían hecho su
trabajo no había mucho más que pudieran
hacer
se desconoce cuántas personas podrían
permanecer en las ruinas de la sería
fortificada de 11 kilómetros cuadrados
pero quien dijo que se concentrará en
sacarlos con vida
francia intensificará el envío de armas
a ucrania según lo hablaron
telefónicamente los mandatarios de ambos
países aunque el comunicado del elíseo
no precisó a cuánto armamento se
referían emanuel manjón y volodymyr se
les quita también hablar de las
garantías de seguridad que el gobierno
galo podría proporcionarle a kiev y los
líderes discutieron además las maneras
para que ucrania reanude la exportación
de sus granos
suecia y finlandia entregarán este
miércoles formalmente su solicitud para
unirse a la otan y el jueves la primera
ministra sueca magdalena anderson y el
presidente finlandés xaulín y listo
viajarán a washington para reunirse con
el presidente estadounidense joe biden
la casa blanca afirmó que confiaba en
que los países miembros de la otan
llegaran a un consenso para aceptar a
las naciones nórdicas y es que el
mandatario de turquía recep tayib
erdogán dijo que se opondría acusando a
estos países de albergar militantes del
partido de los trabajadores del
kurdistán la decisión de la alianza
militar tiene que ser unánime para que
entre en vigor
suecia y finlandia esperan su respaldo
suecia también quiere cooperar con
turquía dentro de la otan ya
esta cooperación puede ser un elemento
nuevo e importante en nuestras
relaciones bilaterales
el valet sostuvo y usuaria por supuesto
suecia se opone a todas las formas de
terrorismo al igual que la otan y la
unión europea no todos turbo com
cambiamos de tema el gobierno británico
presentará un nuevo proyecto de ley al
parlamento que pretende hacer cambios
unilaterales en uno de los acuerdos más
delicados del preside se trata del
llamado protocolo de irlanda del norte
que regula el comercio y el paso entre
este país y su vecino de la unión
europea irlanda aunque londres dice que
estará abierto al diálogo en bruselas se
prendieron las alarmas pues consideran
que sería una violación a un acuerdo
vinculante e internacional aquí les
contamos
dando un giro de 180 grados respecto a
lo acordado en 2019 el gobierno de reino
unido prepara una nueva ley para alterar
el protocolo de irlanda del norte
nuestra preferencia continúa siendo una
solución negociada con la unión europea
y en paralelo a la legislación que
presentamos seguimos abiertos a futuras
conversaciones si podemos conseguir el
mismo resultado mediante un acuerdo
negoció
el protocolo de irlanda del norte es el
principal motivo de parálisis política
en el territorio norirlandés y una
fuente de tensiones desde que entró en
vigor en 2021 pero que es el protocolo
de irlanda del norte- forma parte de los
acuerdos del break sit el marco legal de
separación entre londres y bruselas con
la salida del reino unido- de la unión
europea había que establecer una
frontera para los controles migratorios
y aduaneros de entrada al mercado único
europeo
irlanda del norte es la única parte del
reino unido- que limita por tierra con
la unión europea comparte fronteras con
la república de irlanda sin embargo la
reimposición de nuevas barreras entre
las dos irlandas hacía temer el
resurgimiento de la histórica violencia
entre grupos republicanos y unionistas
de las últimas décadas así que se
decidió establecer los controles en el
mar de irlanda entre territorio
norirlandés y el resto del territorio
británico estas disposiciones conforman
el protocolo de irlanda del norte y ha
recogido por el derecho internacional
pero la solución está lejos de ser
definitiva el partido unionista
democrático de irlanda del norte que
quiere permanecer unido a londres
argumenta que la frontera en el mar de
irlanda socava la posición de irlanda
del norte en el reino unido- por lo que
rechazan aliarse con el sinn fein para
formar el gobierno regional hasta que se
resuelvan las diferencias sobre el
protocolo el sinn fein que quiere la
reunificación con la república de
irlanda y defiende el protocolo ganó las
elecciones de este mayo pero necesita el
apoyo de partidos unionistas para
liderar el ejecutivo por otro lado
downing street- critica la unión europea
por ceñirse al protocolo de forma
inflexible bruselas asegura que
responderá firmemente si londres
continúa adelante con su cambio que
considera una violación flagrante de un
acuerdo internacional
y en españa' intentan fortalecer el
derecho al aborto el consejo de
ministros aprobó el anteproyecto para
ampliar la ley de salud sexual y
reproductiva y de interrupción del
embarazo el gabinete lo votaría la
próxima semana uno de los puntos clave
es permitir que las mujeres puedan
interrumpir su embarazo desde los 16 a
desde los 16 años sin el consentimiento
de sus padres también se plantea una
incapacidad pagada por el estado para
mujeres con fuertes dolores menstruales
y que el seguro de salud proporcione la
píldora anticonceptiva y un permiso de
maternidad adelantado además la
gestación subrogada quedaría
explícitamente descrita como violatoria
de los derechos humanos
es una propuesta transgresor a que las
mujeres han acogido con los brazos
abiertos el gobierno de españa ha
presentado el primer proyecto de ley de
europa para que las trabajadoras puedan
optar por una baja laboral por dolores
menstruales con una reforma dentro de la
ley del aborto si una persona que es
mujer tiene una menstruación que le
impide e impide trabajar o estar
decentemente en un puesto de trabajo ya
que una menstruación fuerte pues puede
ser algo
jodidos si puedo decir eso pues me
parece perfectamente es común que
durante su periodo las mujeres sufran
fuertes dolores menstruales así como
síntomas como diarrea mareos e incluso
vómitos incapacitantes para el desempeño
de cualquier trabajo la situación es más
compleja cuando además son pacientes con
endometriosis una patología en el útero
que afecta entre 10 y 15 por ciento de
las españolas como en el caso de claire
band es una entrenadora personal y no
puede trabajar cuando tiene la regla
manning and ecology fui a tantos médicos
a tantos ginecólogos que no encontraban
nada a pesar de los exámenes a que
finalmente después de un año alrededor
de la navidad' de 2021 empecé a
desmayarme podía sentir que los órganos
vitales me fallaban y coors field my
back on guns and work failing meant el
lento diagnóstico y el desconocimiento
de la enfermedad así como de los
fenómenos asociados a la menstruación
son situaciones con las que el gobierno
de coalición de izquierdas ha prometido
terminar
ir a trabajar con dolor se acabó en
pastillas e antes de llegar al trabajo y
tener que ocultar que esos días estamos
con un dolor que nos incapacita para
trabajar el permiso será pagado desde el
primer día ilimitado pero deberá ser
prescrito por un médico una propuesta
que se espera que el gabinete de
gobierno discuta y apruebe el próximo
martes nos vamos a américa desde el
estado de nueva york donde hubo el
tiroteo masivo que mató a 10 personas
el presidente joe biden afirmó que la
supremacía blanca es un veneno tanto él
como la primera dama jill biden llevaron
flores al monumento improvisado a las
víctimas de búfalo y se reunieron con
los familiares mayoría eran
afroamericanos asesinados por un hombre
blanco el pistolero es una adolescente
que parece ser el autor de un manifiesto
de 180 páginas que habla sobre la teoría
supremacista del gran reemplazo lo que
biden respondió calificando como
terrorismo doméstico
y el supremacismo blanco es un veneno es
un veneno
en realidad
que se esparce por nuestro cuerpo
político y lo hemos dejado pudrir e
hincharse ante nuestros propios ojos no
más
a la cumbre de las américas no contará
con la presencia de otro presidente es
que hoy el mandatario de guatemala
alejandro giammattei anunció que no
acudirá a la reunión que se realizará en
los ángeles en junio previamente sus
homólogos de méxico y de bolivia andrés
manuel lópez obrador y luis arse
afirmaron que tampoco irían si eeuu se
mantiene en su postura de no invitar a
cuba a venezuela y nicaragua además el
anuncio de llama 'the y se produjo un
día después de que washington criticara
la designación de consuelo porras como
la fiscal general de guatemala y es que
ella está en la lista del departamento
de estado sobre agentes corruptos
ahora hacemos un breve repaso sobre
noticias del cob y 19 en el mundo
los menores que tengan entre 5 y 11 años
en eeuu ya podrán aplicarse la dosis de
refuerzo es que la administración de
alimentos y medicamentos fda por sus
siglas en inglés autorizó la vacuna
adicional esta debe ser la de facer y
vayan take
la ciudad de nueva york a aumentó su
nivel de alerta por coronavirus y ahora
está en alto ya que las variantes de
omicron han hecho que el brote se
propague más rápido y ha presionado otra
vez al sistema de salud por la medida se
recomienda usar mascarillas en lugares
cerrados y evitar espacios concurridos
además las autoridades recomiendan
continuar la vacunación como medida para
combatir un rebrote
y la organización mundial de la salud
está alarmada por la creciente
propagación del cob y 19 en corea del
norte el organismo de la onu advirtió
que la población del país asiático era
particularmente vulnerable porque gran
parte no estaba vacunada y reiteró su
oferta de brindar ayuda al país en la
pandemia el gobierno norcoreano no
reportaba datos pero en esta ola ha
confirmado que al menos 15 millones de
personas han tenido fiebre
mientras tanto india continúa sufriendo
las consecuencias de la ola de calor
adelantada y es que hay una aguda
escasez de agua en varias partes del
país una situación que es común durante
los meses de mayo y junio que son los
más calurosos del año en áreas de la
capital nueva delhi camiones cisterna
han estado abasteciendo a los habitantes
pero éstos se quejan de que el
suministro no es suficiente parte desde
el norte sur y oeste del país ya han
registrado temperaturas superiores a los
40 grados centígrados
y terminamos con noticias culturales
porque se inauguró el festival de cine
de cannes el martes los organizadores
del evento desplegaron la alfombra roja
más temprano de lo habitual y poco
después ya estaban reunidas las
estrellas de cine y los asistentes para
esta edición número 75 del festival así
el glamour volvió al resort de la
riviera francesa la primera proyección
fue la película de zombies final cat
y así terminamos las noticias pero los
invitamos a que sigan conectados aquí en
france 24
[Música]